non legati cosa cazzo stia succedendo
prevedi io star wars episodio 7
scommetto che lei è qui perché io non ho
parlato da nessuna parte di star wars
episodio 7 e internet un wall e sapere
la mia opinione non è che perché faccio
video online allora devo dire tutto
quello che vi passa per la testa tutte
le opinioni possibili immaginabili ci
sarà la volta in cui ognuno si fa i
cazzi suo ok ok ok il film non è uscito
posso darti due opinioni sul trailer ma
non ne vado dal tuo cazzo di serie
quello comune sono contento che esca un
nuovo star wars posso essere contento
non ho idea del perché ci sia un chums
che era all'inizio del iii ieri mi sono
cambiato in mano quando l'ho visto cgia
brunson vuole ucciderci tutti non ha
idea
non so perché ci si ha notizia che guida
la scatoletta di tonno non so perché ci
siamo
sta roba qua ma non su un cazzo perché
il film non è uscito ho adorato la prima
de lucia e se posso ammetterlo quando
uscì al cinema la minaccia fantasma ero
comunque con detto e sono uscito dal
cinema felice a ema jalou giovinotto e
mi piacevano le spade laser è il più
piglio dell'astronave quindi si sono
contento di avervi sorelle essi mi piace
quella cazzo di spada probabilmente non
ha una merda di senso fare le sa come
laser ma vada bene uguale c'è da dire
che quando ho visto l'enterprise e
devono dire il millennium falcon mm
fatto sbagliare di prima mille emozioni
sono allora tesi ecco la gita rotto i
[ __ ] per settimane per sapere cosa
ne pensassi di star wars e ne penso
quello che pensa a tutti il film non è
ancora uscito
che cazzo mi sono fumato ieri